certainly we are all pretty well fans of
the silent great actually in
particularly with Sean sheep I mean the
the crew are actually watching a pretty
well on a weekly basis and then several
months before it's great and I think
this thursday lunchtime it always had a
different side comedy on there we'll
bring our favorites in and it's really
valuable I mean they work they are just
as they say bloody brilliant and they
still stand up today so that when you're
doing that very physical comedy you just
want to learn from the crates and
actually velas McGraw was very
interesting because Steve box who was
Nick's collaborate on the wrong trousers
was given the task of finding the
physical character of this little
penguin and he spent I don't know
several weeks trying to work it had his
character was going to move and he
eventually came to the conclusion that
the less he did the more evil he was and
he does very very little indeed and it
reminds me I think it's a matter a
matter of life and death isn't it in the
heaven seen as it were misused stands up
and does his before he's being God and
he just stands there with huge stature
just absolutely nothing and it's sort of
that same sort of principle but I mean
that little little very tiny bit of
black pastor Cena's evil personified
just by the way he blinks yeah yeah I've
we always reference Buster Keaton
immunity is constantly a reference point